that's starting to be delivered
so we will start to uh we're going to be
using that
new vaccination allocation again local
governments don't
schedule any appointments until you
know you have an allocation
from the state which means we get the
allocation from the federal government
we then tell the local governments what
their vaccination is
vaccination usage rate
needles in arms is
much higher than it was again we're at
100 percent but you still see a
differential
across the state
and places that are lower
uh than 100 you know i'd like to see
every region at 100 percent
we are going to get 16 more doses from
the federal government
that is good news that will come
next week and for the following
two weeks we did this on a call with
the white house the governors have been
pushing the federal government for
months
to give us an allocation
of what we're going to get in the next
few weeks
so we can plan this is
incredibly difficult if not impossible
only to tell me what i'm going to get
next week and then i have to scramble to
get the distribution
uh for next week
we now have a three-week allocation
thanks to the biden administration which
is much much better than where we were
so i can then say to local governments
you're going to get 16
more next week and the week after and
the week after
plan on that hospital workers
want a priority they are still the
priority
even though we have a lot of other
categories eligible because
vaccinating hospital workers protects
hospital capacity
if hospitals get overwhelmed i am
telling you what they're going to say
they're going to say we have a staff
shortage
not that nurses and doctors disappeared
but that they got sick
if they are vaccinated they won't get
sick
vaccinate the healthcare workers we're
up to 73 percent
and that is great news uh january 18th
we're 63
we then did a full court press i used my
most persuasive
charm offensive to
convey to hospitals that they had to get
this vaccination done
convey to local governments they had to
get the vaccinations done we went from
63 to 70
in 10 days uh that's a point a day
so that's phenomenal progress and i
thank them all very much for doing a
good job
yes it was urgent yes i said it was
urgent
but they responded and i thank them very
much
again you see a variation across the
state
some places are higher some places are
lower 73 is the average
but places that are below we'd like to
see everybody
rise up this is and there's a variation
by hospitals across the state
these are the top 25 percent
of performing hospitals and the bottom
25 of performing hospitals okay we have
about 200 hospitals give or take in the
state
this is the highest vaccinating
25 and the lowest vaccinating
25 percent uh i can't read this chart
so uh you can read it at your leisure
uh these are the top 25
hospitals not percent top 25 hospitals
and the bottom 25 hospitals
and this i can almost read
sayas at hospital 100 great job cayuga
medical center 100
great job staten island university
hospital 100 percent great job
nyu's nyc new york city health and
hospitals woodhull
100 great job northern westchester
97 very good not great because you're
not a hundred
if you were 100 you'd be great but 97 is
very good
university hospital stony brook 96
good not great
37 percent new york city harlem hospital
center
new york city h h north central bronx
hospital 38
40 montefiore mount vernon health
uh how do you have some hospitals at a
hundred and some hospitals at 37 percent
uh please local departments of health
look into this i will wager you this
if we get into trouble with hospital
capacity
the hospitals that are on the bottom of
this list will be the first
hospitals to have a problem with
hospital capacity
and getting overwhelmed that is my wager
i just hope it never happens bronx
positivity is still high
and we've been talking about this for
weeks it's at 7.06 percent
we're going to open a mess vaccinations
site at yankee stadium
you cannot play baseball when you come
but you can come to yankee stadium
it is a joint effort i want to thank the
city mayor de blasio
i want to thank the yankees randy levine
i told him that we would not disturb the
grass please
honor that commitment somos community
care is actually going to operate it
henry munoz who's done a fantastic job
for this state i want to thank them very
much
and the national guard
will be constructing and administering
the site
and i want to thank all the national
guard people who
i've been out there with them many many
times through covid and many other
emergencies they do a great job
and when i ask them to come out i go out
and i join them and i'm going to join
them at yankee stadium
i'm going to be more of a construction
supervisor
manager role
not that i won't do the heavy lifting dr
zucker
is going to do a lot of the heavy
lifting polls tents
but i will do the supervising of the
operation
any local government that needs help in
providing social equity efforts let us
know
there's two issues on social equity
people have to have access poor
communities black community
latino community and
they have to accept it and get past the
vaccine hesitancy
which we are seeing and it is a very
real issue and we've been talking about
it for weeks and we expected it but it
is a very real issue but
any local government that wants a
specialized effort
we will work with them to do it overall
we're reopening the economy and we're
protecting public health
we said it was never one or the other it
was always both
so it's smart and safe it's following
science and following data
you watch those numbers and you react to
the numbers what is happening with the
positivity what's happening with the new
cases per capita what's happening with
the hospitalization rate
and adjust the economic valve
as follows new york city
we went from 7.1 in january that was our
high point
in new york city it was the high point
across the state that was the
post-holiday
surge high we're down to 4.9 percent
and again all the models project that
number to continue to drop
new york city restaurants on our current
trajectory we can reopen
indoor dining at 25 percent
uh on valentine's day the restaurants
want a period of time
so they can notify workers uh they can
get up to speed for indoor dining order
supplies etc
so we're saying indoor dining 25
on valentine's day going
forward we are very uh excited about the
possibility
of reopening venues with testing
we demonstrated it in buffalo with
buffalo bills playoff game seven
thousand people
tested before they went into the stadium
we've had virtually no cases of
spread from that game seven thousand
people
we're not going to have the full vaccine
for many many months
in new york we want to use testing
as the key to reopening
events and we tested it in buffalo and
we want to start to extend it
we're going to extend it in the new york
state safe
marriage receptions
promise of marital bliss is returning
all patrons who attend the event will be
tested
you get a 50 capacity of the venue up to
150 people
it has to be approved by the local
health department
and this will go into effect march 15th
we are developing more rapid testing
capacity
all across the state we're also
developing
an app which a person once they receive
the test
can have on the app so we're excited
about this
we're also developing guidance much like
marriage receptions for events
where you can do testing and you can do
monitoring
and the local health department can
regulate it so new york says i do
i don't want to create any pressure for
anyone
especially undue pressure i don't want
to create any
personal pressure i don't believe that's
government's
role to create personal pleasure but
here's an idea
that you may want to consider
restaurants are opened on valentine's
day
you could make a reservation now or
plan dinner on valentine's day
you propose on valentine's day
uh and then you can have the wedding
ceremony
march 15th up to 150 people
people will actually come to your
wedding
because you can tell them with the
testing it will be safe everybody there
will have been tested
and everybody will be safe because
for a lot of these venues i don't
believe it's about the government
restrictions i believe if i said today
movie theaters can open to a hundred
percent
i don't believe people go i believe
uh people have to be confident that it's
safe
and if you can say everyone in this
reception is going to be tested uh so
again no pressure but it's just an idea
get engaged on valentine's day on the
rest of iran's reopening
and march 15th you can have the wedding
150 people new york state is exploring
uh a low-cost new york state
engagement ring that we would actually
make available has a little heart on it
little i love new york
a little covered remembrance that's not
true
general caution on all of this we make
decisions based on
facts based on the numbers new york city
numbers down
these numbers are now down but
facts change it sounds
inconsistent we like to think a fact is
always a fact
no facts change
covered facts change dramatically
and they change often there's now
another new term in the coveted lexicon
variants of interest variance of
interest
that's a new one
variants of interest refers to these new
strains that are popping up
that we are just learning about the uk
strain the brazil strain the south
africa strain
and medical experts are saying these
strains
could take over they could be dominant
they could increase the infection rate
uh six weeks
you could have a dominant uk strain that
could increase the infection rate
south africa strain may be more
resistant to a vaccine
i understand all the possibilities
and if there are facts and if the facts
change then we will have a different
situation
one fact one one
state response that is
a given basically our precaution if
any areas hospital capacity
hits 85 percent then we go back to
restrictions right
because hospital capacity is
the red line that's that's when you're
in the danger zone
hospital capacity that's why i'm so
persistent on the vaccination of health
care workers
but uh we are subject to the facts
if the facts change uh i mentioned this
the other day
i had a conversation with one of my
daughters who has all sorts of what-if
scenarios what if it's true about the uk
varia a variant becomes dominant
what if the south africa strain
is vaccine resistant what if the brazil
strain
connects with the uk strain connects
with
another strain what if this what if this
would have this
yeah there are possible scenarios
that could develop that are problematic
that is true
this is the same daughter who said don't
tell me to relax
tell me why i should relax
i understand the anxiety i feel the
anxiety
i don't like knowing
what is going to happen in three weeks
or four weeks or five weeks or six weeks
i don't like the feeling of being out of
control i don't like the feeling that
you can wake up any morning
and there's going to be a headline that
says there's a new variant
that is vaccine resistant there's a new
variant
because this this virus is mutating all
the time
there are not five or six mutations of
this virus there are hundreds and
hundreds of mutations of this virus
and remember the flu virus every year
you get a new vaccine
because it changes a little bit so
yes i feel the anxiety
and i feel that we're not in control
and yes i like to be in control
uh control freaks yeah i like to be in
control
i like to know what's coming down the
road so i can prepare
this is the situation where nobody knows
what's coming down the road
nobody knows i talk to the best experts
that have a theory maybe this maybe that
maybe this but nobody knows
so what do you do you deal with the
facts
when you know them if the numbers change
we change if the enemy changes we change
if the infection rates changes we change
if a variant comes we change well why
should i feel
calm about that because we have
proven multiple times
that we can manage changes
that develop we managed
the greatest change in this
country this state had more infections
at one time
than any country on the globe
this state and we were alone
when we got ambushed and coveted came
and nobody
knew was here for months nobody knew
we dealt with it the infection rate went
crazy we dealt with it
hospitals were overwhelmed we were
right on the brink of hospital capacity
collapse like california
like italy but it didn't happen
because we handled it
we handled the fall surge
we handled the holiday search
if the facts change we will handle it
should it relax us no doesn't relax me
but i believe whatever happens
we can manage it because we have already
managed the worst that has happened in
this
country so i am confident
that if the facts change the
circumstances change
we will manage it i can't predict what
it will be
but i am confident that whatever it is
we can handle it
the reality on the vaccines
all of this is subject now to the
production capacity of private drug
companies
and the united states ability to procure
it's not about distribution
we have far more distribution capacity
than we have supply
we have thousands of distributors and
more distributors that can be brought
online
the question is not really supply
the most accurate way to say supply is
it's a question of production
uh united states government right now is
a pass-through
right you have private drug companies
producing
fizer johnson johnson hopefully
moderna novo vax they're producing
the us procures it and then the u.s
sends it to us but
the faucet is the private production
we'll distribute all that we receive
but even with president biden's
new announcement of increase which is
very welcome it's six to nine
months to get enough vaccine to
vaccinate people in this country
i think president biden the federal
government should now consider
the defense production act we went
through this in the spring
and we paid a very high price for it
when we ran out of ppe we ran out of
reagents for testing and we ran out of
q-tips
they call them nasal swabs i call them
big q-tips
and we ran out of ventilators and
the manufacturers could not produce any
more
ventilators what the defense production
act says is
the federal government can say to
private companies
you must produce this product
the problem on the drug production the
vaccine production
is the manufacturing capacity of the
drug
these are very specialized machines
specialized equipment
this is not going to go away anytime
soon
there probably will be a new virus
that requires a new vaccine and a new
booster shot if you will this is going
to be
multiple years use the defense
production
act let's
increase our manufacturing capacity
of the drug
this is a war the defense production act
was used in wartime
that's what the previous administration
said to me well that's for war time
this is war time this is covet is a war
more americans died from covet than
world war one world war
ii korea vietnam combined
so yes we are at war use the defense
production act
because this is not about the next six
to nine months this is about the next
two to three years
new york state needs federal fairness
and they're discussing the covid relief
package now
we need 15 billion dollars in federal
relief and we need
salt repealed
on the coveted relief finally
president biden thank you put in state
and local
financing 350 million dollars the
governors democrat and republican
have been calling for that for over a
year
we need 15 of the 350 we need 15
of however they make the sausage between
the senate and the house
we need 15 billion in federal relief
and this is a fair request
new york state was ground zero new york
state had a different problem with
covert than any other
that is a fact yes i am the new york
governor
and yes i fight for the people of new
york that is my job
i represent the people of the state of
new york and i will fight for them and
advocate for them
but i have no problem saying to any
governor in this state
which i have new york had a different
problem than you had
new york was ambushed new york got hit
harder
new york was hurt by the federal
negligence
for letting the dam virus come here
without telling us
new york law lost more people
new york was the laboratory for all the
other states to watch
so they had notice
new york was ground zero we expect
fairness
from the federal government but we also
demand
fairness from the federal government
and to my federal colleagues
congress people senators
there are no excuses now you
are in charge you are in many ways
executives the buck stops with you
democrats control the senate democrats
control the house we have a democratic
president
this is a different time in history
there is no one to point the finger to
we need you to deliver for new york
and when it comes from to salt salt was
just a political
theft what they did in the federal
government was they increased our taxes
and they gave it to republican states
because they had republican control
and their theory was if you can do it
do it it wasn't fair wasn't just
it was pure politics they took from the
blue states they gave to the red
and the state that they took from most
was new york state
and new jersey and massachusetts and
california and connecticut they took the
most
from those states and those are all
northeastern states
and it hurt the northeastern economy and
they gave it
to the republican states every democrat
every democratic congress person every
democratic senator
said it was an outrage and we'll fix it
well you know what fix it
because now you're in charge i'm going
to organize
a national assault repeal effort this is
not just about
new york this is about all the states
work that were hurt
public safety is a top priority we want
to talk about the economy coming back
the economy does not come back
unless people know it's safe cities
don't come back unless people know
cities are safe
that is a blunt truth
we all understand the tension between
police and certain members of the
community
loss of trust loss of respect that's
been true for over a year
i've said numerous times problems don't
go away
if you deny them they only mount they
get worse
it's true in life it's true in society
it's true in government
government leaders put people at the
table work it out
make it a cathartic collaborative
process
police have the police they have to be
able to do their job safely
the community has to believe they're
treated fairly
and they're not discriminated against
and they're not abused
come up with a new plan a new
understanding but do it by april 1.
april 1 is only 62 days away many
localities are doing a great job
we have other localities that are trying
to ignore the problem
the problem won't go away ignoring it
will
not address it it's a failure of
leadership
uh and the problem will only compound
because in april 1
that locality will not be eligible for
state funding
so 62 days
bottom line the vaccine is scarce
everybody wants more and i said when
this started
everybody's going to say the same thing
including me
everybody wants more when i get on the
phone with the white house i say
i want more every county executive says
it
every group says it the vaccine is
scarce
we are rationing the vaccine that is
what we are doing
and we are rationing it fairly
there are 1.3 million healthcare workers
they get 21 there are 1.7
million essential workers they get 27
this 65 plus 3.2 million they get 52
that's the percent of the population
they are
i'm not picking a healthcare worker over
an essential worker
over a 65-plus person
we're doing it fairly by population
because
every life is as valuable as every other
life
and these were the national priorities
that were set
and we're doing it fairly and i feel
good about that
i'm saying to my local colleagues don't
play politics
with vaccines don't play politics in
this
moment you have health care workers
you have long-term care facility
residents
long-term care facilities staff
developmentally disabled staff
college professors police officers
fire professionals mass transit
professionals
grocery store workers child care
and then you have people who are 65 plus
it is divisive
for a politician to say well i think
police should get more
i think grocery store workers should get
more
i think nurses should get more
it's divisive and it's cheap
yes you want to be a hero to the police
you
say i think the police should get more
it's
cheap because if you want to be honest
you think the police should get more who
on the list would you take it from
would you take it from the nurses would
you take it from the doctors
would you take it from 65 plus
it's a zero-sum game
you can't stand up and play hero
to any one group on that list
if you have any sense of honor
or integrity where would you take it
from
i believe healthcare workers should get
more
i believe development disabled workers
should get more
i believe school teachers should get
more i believe
first responders should get more i
believe the subway and bus drivers
should get more i believe grocery store
workers should get more
yes i believe daycare workers should get
more
yes but
if you want to say well they're not
getting their fair share
then say at the same time who you would
take it
from on that list
otherwise you're playing politics
you're dividing people you're scaring
people
you're upsetting people at a very
delicate time
we get 300 000 vaccines per week
to do seven million people
you can't do every one group
at least do it fairly political
extremism
is a country a problem in this country
we've seen it in washington
d.c they're now doing investigations
government cannot tolerate criminal
insurrection
and new yorkers will not tolerate it
there are levels of extremism
what happened in washington did not just
happen out of night overnight
it developed and you could see it
increasing
over time it was a building storm
and it starts with ugliness
and threats on the internet
anonymous threats
we should confront them we should get
them we should attack
them this is the
internet social media can really be a
breeding ground
for a lot of positive but also for a lot
of hate
and it builds i see it here in new york
on the internet uh this building
ugliness uh once you start to light
fires don't be surprised when the fire
is out of control that was the lesson of
what happened in washington
uh and that was the lesson that i hope
many of the extremists learned in
washington
unfortunately i don't think they did
because we see it here in new york
first of all the laws is the law
and in new york i will never allow
the insurrection that happened in
washington d.c uh that made a mockery
of law and order uh and that was a
disgrace
to democracy and to every citizen of
this nation
uh second uh
when you see the ugliness being
fomented for selfish
political reasons often
everybody should condemn it everybody
should condemn it
there are no secrets in life we know
who spreads the ugliness
on the internet you can think i'm
anonymous
capital watch you're not anonymous
people know who you are and who you work
for
and any decent
elected official i don't care democrat
republican you want to have differences
have differences i represent democrats
and republicans
but don't get ugly and don't get ugly
now
when society is so fragile
and personalities are under such
stress times of extreme
pressure show us who we are
times of pressure reveal
the true character in people i believe
that
over this past year with covet i've
learned
so much about individuals
about myself and about
society and about new yorkers
you put pressure on people and
any little personality crack or
flaw when you put the pressure on it
explodes
little insecurities explode
and little neuroses explode
people who i thought were strong and
capable
crumbled i saw them crumble during
covert
at the same time you put the pressure on
you put the stress on
it it solidifies the stone
it makes some people stronger
and i've seen people rise up
and really respond to their better
angels new yorkers
by and large did that that's how we beat
covert
you see the beauty in people
and you see the ugliness in people
it is disturbingly
exposing find
your best self in this moment
and let's all of us applaud
each other when we find our best selves
and let's strive for that that's what we
mean when we say
new york tough not
tough the way they always think yeah
with that yes we are tough
but we're more than just tough
we're smart we
are united we're disciplined and we're
strong enough
to love that's what we have to find in
this moment and that's what we have
found
and when you don't see that speak up
speak up this
is our ethos and this is our morality
and this is what we expect from each
other to be new york tough
and if you're not
speak up questions
thank you governor if you would like to
ask a question please use the raise hand
function at the bottom of your window
we'll take a brief moment to compile the
q a roster
governor your first question comes from
chris ravatas from wivb
chris your line is now open please
unmute your microphone
good afternoon governor why should it
take a report from the attorney general
for the state
to release the number of nursing home
residents who died in a hospital which
is a number
uh that we've been looking for for quite
a while
uh let me use dr zucker first to
respond to that sure thank you governor
there
are a few key points here that i'd like
to make which is that you know we've
always
been transparent on the number of
nursing home deaths that were reported
in the facility we've always said those
are the in facility
deaths and we've also said that there
have been hospital deaths
back in august we said that we would get
the
legislature the number and we're working
on that
particularly in anticipation of my
budget hearing which is coming up next
month
but when when i saw the
attorney general report decided that we
need to finish that up quickly
and get these numbers out in real time
the other key point this is a very
important point to emphasize is that
the total number of deaths does not
change
that number uh has not changed and we
put that out to misrepresent that number
actually
is factually inaccurate and so uh in the
report when when
i saw that uh that was there i said that
that
when they said there was under counting
that's just actually inaccurate
we wanted to get that out and governor
as we as you have said on all these
presentations
uh reporting the number of deaths is
always the hardest number to report out
there and we wanted to be sure
uh that that those numbers were accurate
thank you
yeah very just the uh also for the
remember the context here
the report affirmed everything the
commissioner said
uh where this starts is
uh frankly a political attack
from prior federal administration hhs
their great spokesperson michael caputo
who's roger stone protege who said
we had more nursing home deaths in new
york because of something that the state
health department did
uh this report affirms everything the
commissioner said for the past year
the state department of health
followed federal guidance
by cms and cdc
commissioners said no not-for-profit
nursing home was forced to take anyone
report confirms that if they took a
person
who was not who they could not care for
a covet positive person they violated
the law
the report says that
and the department of health only
counted the number of
deaths in hospitals and the number of
deaths in
nursing homes released that number that
number stays the same
well how about people who were
in people who were transferred
from a hospital back to a nursing home
that number the department was
correlating because you have to get that
from the nursing homes
and the report also says the information
from nursing homes is often
uh incorrect uh
and that's the number to
date but it's an ongoing process
next question
governor your next question comes from
jennifer lukey from whec
jennifer your line is now open please
unmute your microphone
good afternoon governor your staff is
often unapologetically aggressive when
it comes to defending your policies
particularly on social media
but in this case many of the people who
disagree with how this whole situation
was handled with the nursing homes
have a very personal connection to it
they've lost someone in the pandemic
tied to a nursing home so the policy
aside who was right who was wrong
just as a father as a son what would
your message be
to those families today
what i would say is
everyone did the best they could
uh when i say
the state department of health as the
report said the state department of
health followed federal guidance
so uh if you think there was a mistake
then go talk to the federal government
it's not about
pointing fingers or blame it's that this
became a political football
right uh look whether a person died
in a hospital or died in a nursing home
it's the people died
people died i was in a hospital i got
transferred to a nursing home
and my father died my father was in a
nursing home got transferred to a
hospital
my father died
people died
by the way the same people are dying
today
96 of the people who die
are older people with comorbidities
which happens to be the population that
lives in nursing homes
it's continuing today
even with all the testing that we're
doing
if you look at new york state
we have a lower percentage of deaths in
nursing homes
than other states
a third of all deaths in this nation are
from nursing homes
new york state we're only about 28 only
but we're below the national average in
number of deaths in nursing homes
but who cares 33 28
died in a hospital died in a nursing
home
they died and
i dealt with the loss of my father
the pain is so incredible
and inexplicable
and why and why and why
it's a tragedy it's a tragedy
and i understand maybe
the instinct to to blame or to find
some relief for the pain that you're
feeling
but it is a tragedy and it's a tragedy
that continues today
i don't believe i believe everybody did
the best they could
i believe the federal government cdc
i believe they gave the best guidance
they could
i believe they give the best guidance
they can today
i believe the state department of health
they gave their best
guidance and made the best decisions on
the facts they had
but doesn't mean people didn't die and
it doesn't mean people won't die today
and people won't die tomorrow and it
doesn't mean that i'm not going to get
up here tomorrow
or monday and read a death number on
that screen
and think about the
100 people who died and then the
hundreds of family members who were home
crying that day
and that's going to continue that is the
curse of covet
can you protect old people with
comorbidities
from covet
totally no no
if we could it would be over
if it wasn't over last year would have
been over by now right
it's still not over
so i understand the pain
uh i understand that the search for
answers
uh but it was a tragedy
and i i feel the anguish
and i feel the pain
and i get the anger
my father died i wish i had someone to
blame
it would make me feel better maybe
but they're in my thoughts and prayers
uh i believe why
covered why did god do this
uh i don't know i don't know
but it was cruel and it was terrible and
it still is
uh and
uh luckily i'm blessed with faith
and that helped me at times of pain
but uh my heart goes out to each and
every one
and i feel it personally and everybody
should know it's
it's not because and when i do the death
numbers on monday it's not because
everyone didn't do
everything they could to prevent it
next question
governor your next question comes from
james ford
of wpix james your line is now open
please unmute your microphone
thank you governor i appreciate that
time
uh regarding the lifting
of the indoor dining ban
in new york city some restaurateurs say
that
25 capacity still isn't enough
to save their businesses what's your
message to them
also your presentation said the
production of vaccines
needs to be increased including the
johnson and johnson vaccine
its efficacy we're now seeing is at
about
70 so lower than the others that are
available
what role could it and any
vaccine that might not be able to
protect against new strains of the virus
what roles can they play in the state's
vaccination program sir
yeah two points first uh uh some
restaurants say 25
isn't enough look 25 percent is better
than zero
and that's where we are now uh if the
numbers continue to get better
that number will go up uh if
uh hell uh
develops and the sky
falls and a new variant uh
explodes onto the scene then uh
we'll have the opposite problem
statewide
but if the numbers continue to get
better
then we will continue to increase the
numbers
right it's it's an economic
metric it's a number
well 25 isn't enough you can't find the
business owner
who will say uh they don't want to do
more
you can won't find a school that says
they don't wish they could be at a
hundred percent
uh occupancy you won't find the theater
that says they won't be at a hundred
percent
they'd rather not uh they'd rather be at
100
occupancy that's true for every business
in the state that's true for every
business in the country
that's true for every uh country on the
globe
if you ask people well do you want to
get covered
every person will say no all right so
balance those two
facts right uh
balance the fact that uh
old people with comorbidities covet is
almost a death sentence
balance those facts and that's what
we're trying to do
so 25 percent if the numbers keep coming
down then we would increase to 25
percent on johnson johnson
let me just make sure we're clear i'm
not commenting on
any one drugs efficacy or effectiveness
i don't believe johnson johnson is even
approved yet
it's supposed to be in the pipeline to
be approved
it has certain advantages a single dose
no cold storage which is a big deal
but i don't know uh i don't do
we're not in charge of i've no knowledge
about the efficacy the efficacy against
strains
how it compares to pfizer how it
compares to moderna
my point is what the defense production
act
allows a president to do is increase
manufacturing capacity
and i think we're going to have to
increase manufacturing capacity
for the best of these drugs
to get to scale because
what is controlling everything and what
you're going to hear for the next
six months from every state
from me if we had more we could
distribute more if we had more we could
vaccinate more
if we had more we could vaccinate more
all this pent up frustration
police want more firefighters want more
politicians say
i think the police should get more i
think the firefighters should get more
yeah all that
tumult that anxiety is because you have
7 million people eligible for three
hundred thousand vaccines
that's the situation that the federal
government created
uh all those sixty five-year-olds who
can't get a vaccine
uh that's not going to end until
the production increases and i don't
believe we're talking about six to nine
months
i believe this virus is going to be
around a long time
and i believe it will mutate and i
believe
it's not inconceivable but that you're
going to need
different vaccines or booster shots in
the future
so i don't believe this issue of
production
is going to go away i believe it's going
to get worse
what we learned with ventilators in the
spring was
the president should have done the
defense production act right away
should have had manufacturers producing
those ventilators right away
should have mandated ppe manufacturing
right away
and rather than wasting the months
that they spent where businesses decided
who wanted to get into the ventilator
business
we actually ultimately produced the
ventilators as a nation
unfortunately we produced them
at a time after we needed them we now
have an abundance
of ventilators i will sell you
10 000 ventilators
but they came too late
defense production act should have been
done early
so the production was increased and i'm
saying the same thing here
next question operator governor your
next question
comes from julia papa of 10 10 wins
julia
your line is now open please unmute your
microphone
okay thank you good afternoon governor
um
actually i have um two questions why did
you count hospital deaths
separately from nursing home deaths and
going forward is there a plan to do that
differently
and also given the success of the
buffalo bills game
and testing and allowing wedding
receptions what are your plans for
baseball
and for broadway ah
the uh
we count hospital deaths correct me from
wrong we count hospital deaths
the department of health counts
deaths in the facilities where they
occurred
so if you die in a hospital
that's the hospital death number if you
die in a nursing home
that's the nursing home number you add
the two numbers together
that's the total death number
uh and that's the way they've been doing
record keeping is that right doctor once
you because i'm sure
the governor is correct about that and
you have to remember historically
when this began most people were dying
in the hospital right initially before
we
uh had situations in the nursing homes
we people were transferred to the
hospital and we were tracking the
hospital numbers
and then we realized that people are
dying nursing homes we track those
numbers but it's important to know where
someone dies and and to
uh to put that down as the governor said
we track both of them
and then we add them and then one other
together
that i want to make if you all recall
since the beginning of this pandemic
the federal government never gave any
state clear guidelines on how they
should be reporting
anything frankly to date 13 states
report
absolutely zero data on nursing home
deaths and only nine states in the
country new york being one of them
gives the presumed number so i would
argue at this point new york puts out
more data on deaths
than any other state in the country and
at the beginning of this
when it was a real crush you had nursing
homes reporting deaths you had hospital
reporting deaths and
i remember d.o.h was trying to determine
whether or not there was going to be
double counting
and the cleanest way to do that was to
say do it where the person died and then
after the fact we'll go back and do a
full audit which is what's happened now
yeah but you you're right the
the numbers the the bottom line number
doesn't change
uh you die in a hospital you've done a
facility you had that together that's
your
total number uh well we wanted to look
at sub numbers
how many went from a hospital to a
nursing home how many went from a
nursing home to a hospital how many
were in both they're talking about
sub numbers within the total number
again which started with this theory
that the state department of health
did something wrong when it came to
nursing homes but the report says as a
matter of fact they didn't which is what
the commissioner said all along
the baseball theaters
first we have a whole pop-up arts
program
which is going to operate separately
which is going to jump start the arts
especially in new york city
and i announced that in the state of the
state i'm going to have more to say
about that in the next couple of weeks
but that's going to be exciting
that is uh how do you jumpstart the arts
uh in a specific
uh sort of one-off way right
just to get the energy back up and the
entertainment back up and you have
actors who haven't worked in a long time
and musicians who haven't worked so
finding venues that are safe uh
outdoor venues very creative
and that's the pop-up arts
effort we're going to have on theaters
baseball station as baseball season
first you have to look at where we are
with the overall trajectory in the
numbers but i believe this
this testing before has a lot of promise
and uh it can't be we wait for the
vaccine because it's too long
and my argument has been and we tried it
with the buffalo
bills if you test people
before they go in and you know they're
negative
then you have a certainty about the
virus right if you don't have it you
can't spread it
and buffalo biz was sort of an extreme
demonstration because it was seven
thousand
and i was outside put seven thousand
people
uh we're now applying that to uh
marriage ceremonies 150 people 50
percent
but you're tested but the local health
department
approved it monitored to make sure you
were tested
could you start to apply that to
different venues i say yes
what do you need more rapid testing
which we're working on and uh
proof that you took a test but i think
the rapid testing is going to be
a key to reopening the economy
next question operator anyone have
anything to add
anything i said mistakens of facts
governor your next question comes from
dave evans at wabc
dave your line is now open please unmute
your microphone
governor can you hear me yes sir dave
how are we doing
hey i like your valentine's day idea um
but i i wanted to ask about
if i could for a second jumping back to
the nursing home
my question is when we look back at that
period of
may june and july when the deaths were
so high
and folks weren't segregated when they
came from the hospital back to the
nursing homes
do you wish that things had been handled
differently that you had better guidance
from the cdc
or from the health department that
things were handled differently
uh well dave let's make sure we're clear
on the facts the
uh federal guidance
said that people
who were in hospitals
but who would presume not contagious
could go back to a nursing home which
could
handle them not all nursing homes can
handle them
and the nursing home had to by law
say that they could handle those people
now the oag's report in the department
of health has said uh
if a nursing home accepted the person
and couldn't handle the person
then they violated the law and uh
that has to be justified because that's
not just there in kobe
that's a nursing home should never take
a person who they
can't handle uh
and uh that's that's an ongoing concern
because if they accept the covet person
do they accept the person with pneumonia
do they accept the person
with any disease uh that they can't
handle appropriately
but do i wish
i wish this never happened dave
i wish none of it happened i wish there
was no covet
i wish no old people died i wish
i didn't have to call out national guard
who got sick some of whom got sick and
died i wish i didn't have to ask
essential workers to leave their homes
bus drivers some of whom got sick and
died
i wish i didn't have to ask the nurses
and the doctors
to work around the clock and deal with
hell some of whom got sick and died
i wish none of it happened that's what i
wish
and if i could add one other thing on
this point
what we found when we went back and
looked at this data was that
between march and june 37
500 staff members who worked in nursing
homes had coveted during the period of
those months
and one of the earliest misconceptions
and mistakes from the health community
was this perception that asymptomatic
spread was not going to be a problem
and so that was something that we've
learned from and that we've made
dramatic changes on in terms of
mandating
testing in facilities when the coveted
positivity was lower over the summer it
was once weekly
we're now back up to twice weekly
statewide and
the unfortunate thing about this virus
and the people that it preys on
is that every day roughly 40 of the
people that we're reporting in that
death number still come from nursing
homes
despite twice weekly testing despite the
vaccines that's going on right now
those numbers are still continuing to be
that high
and when you look at it nationally and
you see that
35 of all deaths in this country of the
430 000 deaths are nursing home deaths
this is something
every state in the country continues to
struggle with is it a trap
it is a tragedy for every family who
comes into contact with this virus
you look just across the border in
pennsylvania 11 170 nursing home deaths
their population is obviously lower than
ours their overall cova death numbers
are obviously lower than ours
florida 9 328 deaths whereas their
overall coveted number of deaths is
lower than ours they weren't hit
in the spring and so this is a virus
that is very difficult to tackle it's a
virus that's very difficult to control
once it gets into this population
and the only model that we've ever seen
that's been completely successful in
keeping
out of nursing homes was there was this
one study that was done of a nursing
home in france where they literally
hermetically sealed it and didn't let
anyone go in and out and the staff lived
there
and short of that this is something that
is very difficult although we all get up
every morning striving to do better and
striving to make sure that these nursing
homes
are doing better for the families that
they serve
yeah and dave let me add something else
the what do you wish
when i say experts in air quotes
it sounds like i'm saying i don't really
trust the experts
because i don't because i don't
you want to talk about making mistakes
how did covet come here for three months
and nobody knew
how did covert leave china go to europe
and come here
and all these federal watchdogs nobody
knew it
how did you let new york sit here for
three months receiving passengers from
europe
who had the virus and nobody knew how
did you tell us that
to spread the disease you had to be
symptomatic
which meant the sneezing the coughing
that's how it spread
only to do a total 180 degrees later
and say oh by the way
you can be asymptomatic and spread it
what that's all the difference in the
world
it got into nursing homes
because it was here before anyone knew
it was brought in by staff it was
brought in by visitors
once it was here they said it was spread
by symptomatic people
that was untrue it was also spread by
asymptomatic people
but then to play politics with it the
way they did
that was mean that was mean
when the trump administration was trying
to
divert blame so they said well
the state uh the states
not just new york by the way they blamed
all the democratic states
for the deaths in nursing homes
the politics wasn't just here in new
york it was all the democratic governors
it was new jersey connecticut
pennsylvania blame all the democratic
governors
for the deaths in nursing homes
no that was mean because if you lost
someone in a nursing home
then it put a thought in your head well
maybe it didn't have to be
maybe my father died unnecessarily
and that was just cruel to do
that was just cruel because it wasn't
true
it wasn't true and melissa's point you
know how
you know it's not true the same
death rate is happening today
and it's higher than the death rate in
new york hospital in new york nursing
homes
it's higher today
today it's happening
what could have been done differently
what could have been done differently
it's still happening today
one more question
governor your last question comes from
morgan mackay of spectrum news
morgan your line is now open please
unmute your microphone
hello governor how are you hey morgan
hi so um you know the question isn't
really about having these
total um coven 19 deaths i think
everyone knows
that um although the total might be
correct
it's all about having the accurate
number of nursing home covenant 19
deaths because
as you know having an accurate number is
extremely important in crafting policy
and legislation
would you support an investigation into
the health department and how they
handle this nursing home situation
do you think they need more staff or
different leadership if they could
agree that having an accurate number for
shaping future policy
is important third question you also
signed a bill in march that provides
immunity for health care providers when
it comes to covenanting cases
this summer when the legislature came
back they narrowed the school slightly
for future instance
now there is a bipartisan push to repeal
this law
do you support this yeah i haven't seen
the bill on the immunity law
second the department of health
produced the nursing home number and the
hospital number
the categorization they're looking for
are people who were transferred
to well people looking for different
things people who were transferred
from hospitals to nursing homes and some
people
are looking for a number of people
transferred from
hospitals back to nursing homes and
nursing homes back to hospitals
those are going to be sub allocations
the department of health
said they can only get that from the
nursing homes and remember the nursing
homes were doing all this data at a very
hectic period the oig's report also says
uh the data from the nursing homes is
very sketchy and
that's why the department of health is
my understanding doctor can correct me
if i'm wrong
has been auditing the data to make sure
what they get from the nursing homes is
actually accurate and
correlating with hospitals but uh
they will have the best information they
can get
from the nursing homes because they
don't create this data it all comes from
the nursing homes
you understand no i would just say again
i'm sorry doctor
and there's two different systems where
the data comes in there's a system that
brings in the data into the hospitals as
a different system brings it into the
nursing homes
uh and we look all the state to be sure
that it's accurate
i should also add to that that again at
the very beginning of this
there was duplicative reporting that was
going on we had the hospitals reporting
numbers we had the nursing home
reporting numbers and we were fearful on
the onset that we were going to be
reporting numbers twice and then we
wouldn't have an accurate picture
of what was happening in coveted new
york again 13 states in the country
report absolutely no data on nursing
homes and only nine states in the
country
report presumed new york being one of
them so
at this point i believe that we give
more data than any other state
in the country and as the doctor said um
this was information that we had always
planned on releasing we were looking to
do it ahead of the legislative
hearings that were upcoming and the
audit continues to be ongoing
but looking for better national guidance
in terms of what is expected on
reporting so you can actually get a
clearer picture
state to state because right now you
really have a difficult time
comparing any states and the states
still are doing reporting that is spotty
at best
okay okay operator uh all of you guys
thank you very much for taking the time
today have a good weekend and we will
talk to you next week
thank you